>> Judge Jeanine: ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ THINKS YOU ARE A
SUCKER IF YOU WORKED HARD AND
PAID OFF YOUR STUDENT DEBT.
THE RADICAL CONGRESSWOMAN
RESPONDING TO A QUESTION ON HOW
BIDEN'S PLAN WOULD BENEFIT THOSE
WHO HAVE ALREADY PAID OFF THEIR
LOANS, QUOTE?
I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE AND I WILL
SAY IT AGAIN.
NOT EVERY PROGRAM HAS TO BE FOR
EVERYBODY.
PEOPLE WITH APARTMENTS PAID FOR
FIRST TIME HOMEOWNER'S BENEFITS.
YOUNGER PEOPLE PAY FOR MEDICAID
FOR SENIORS.
PEOPLE WHO TAKE PUBLIC TRANSIT
PAY FOR CAR INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALL RIGHT, MAKES SENSE TO ME,
HOW ABOUT YOU, GREG?
>> Greg: I PAY FOR EVERYTHING.
I GET NOTHING.
NOTHING.
I LOVE HOW SHE EXPLAINS IT.
THEY ARE NOT MEANT FOR YOU,
RIGHT?
BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO ASK OKAY,
THEN WHAT IS THIS DEBT
FORGIVENESS?
WHO IS IT MEANT FOR?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DATA IT'S
UPPER WHITE MIDDLE CLASS WOMEN.
THIS AIN'T WELFARE, RIGHT?
THESE ARE WELL TO DO PEOPLE.
IT'S A BRIBE FOR DEMOCRATS ON
THE BACKS OF PLUMBERS, TRUCKERS
AND EVERYONE ELSE WHO ACTUALLY
DOES A REAL JOB UNLIKE ME.
AOC IS THE SYMBOL OF THE
ENTITLED PONG.
SHE COMPLAINS ABOUT STUDENT
LOANS.
BUT SHE OWNS A TESLA AND WORSE
SHE OWNS A FRENCH BULLDOG THANKS
TO KAT TIMPF I KNOW EVERYTHING
ABOUT FRENCH BULLDOGS.
ONE THING I KNOW THEY ARE SO
EXPENSIVE.
THEY ARE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN ANY
COLLEGE TUITION THAT YOU HAVE
GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
THEY ARE ADORABLE DOGS BUT SHE
OWNS A TESLA AND SHE OWNS A
FRENCH BULLDOG AND SHE WANTS YOU
OR YOUR DAD, THE ELECTRICIAN TO
FORGIVE HER STUDENT LOAN.
THAT'S B.S.
TURN IN THE TESLA, SELL THE DOG.
I WILL BYE BUY HALF PRICE.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT,
DANA, I WILL GO DOWN THE ROAD R.
TODAY EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
INCREASED.
THERE ARE 11.5 MILLION JOBS
AVAILABLE.
SO, THIS WHOLE ARGUMENT THAT WE
HAVE TO CANCEL THEIR STUDENT
DEBT IS BASED ON WHAT OTHER THAN
BUYING VOTES?
THERE ARE SO MANY JOBS.
>> Dana: ALSO SAY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC UNLESS IT'S AT THE
BORDER THEN IT'S IN THE
PANDEMIC.
SO YOU SEE THEIR LOGIC THERE.
THE THING IS ABOUT HER THEY GIVE
90% OF THE GOFT TOP 60% OF
INCOME.
WHO ARE THEY ACTUALLY TRYING TO
HELP.
THE OTHER THING WHEN YOU MENTION
SHE HAS AS AT THELA, YOU GET A
TAX CREDIT FOR THAT ALSO HAVE A
GREEN VEHICLE ALSO FOR THE
WEALTHY.
THIS IS ALL SO MADDENING.
>> Greg: SWEAR, DANA.
>> Dana: I'M BAFFLED BY AOC AND
OTHERS THAT ARE JUST DEMANDING
THAT JOE BIDEN TAKE EXECUTIVE
ACTION BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PASS
ANY LAWS.
THEY ARE NOT PERSUASIVE ENOUGH
TO PASS ANY LAWS SO THEY HAVE
TO -- THEY TRY HAVE A KING DO
IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT'S
INTERESTING, JOEY, HIS NAME IS
ROW CAN A HANNA HAS PLANS TO
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION
CONGRESSMAN TO CANCEL STUDENT
LOANS EMPHASIZING EVEN THOUGH
BIDEN HAS THE POWER TO DO IT.
>> Joey: IS HE ACTUALLY A PRETTY
MODERATE MEMBER RESPECTIVELY FOR
THE SQUAD.
MY NOT DEMOCRATS WHAT I EXPECT
THEM TO ASK FOR.
MY IS WITH THE REPUBLICANS.
THEY SHOULD CALL THE 3W4RU6 THE
SAME WAY DEMOCRATS HAVE REFUSED
TO CALL THE BLUFF ON THE WALLS
WENT TORE STIEWTS DIDN'T PAY FOR
LEG AND LEG LIKE I DID.
NOW YOU WANT TO GIVE ALL THOSE
PEOPLE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
FORGIVENESS.
LET'S DO A TAX CREDIT FOR
EVERYBODY WHO HAS ALREADY PAID
THEIRS OFF FOR THE NEXT HOW MANY
YEARS YOU GET THAT BACK.
INCLUDE TRADE SCHOOLS.
THE LET'S NOT JUST MEANS TEST
THE PEOPLE GETTING THE STUDENT
LOAN FORGIVENESS.
MEANS TEST THE DEGREE.
IF IT COMES OUT TO THE MOST
EXPENSIVE DEGREE YIELD A MUCH
LOWER INCOME PUT LEGISLATION ON
UNIVERSITY TO NOT CHARGE BE A
SOSHT NANT AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
WORTHLESS DEGREE AND GIVE THE
TRADE SCHOOLS.
>> Judge Jeanine: JESSICA, FINAL
WORD?
>> Jessica: I THINK I LIKE ALL
OF IT THIS IS THE NEIL ISSUE,
RIGHT?
HAD BEFORE THE LAST ELECTION
THIS HAS TO GET THROUGH NOW IT'S
TURNED INTO THIS MOST
INTERESTING THING I READ ABOUT
WHY THIS PROBLEM OR EDUCATION
PROBLEM NOT IN TERMS OF THE
DEGREE THAT YOU GOT IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE GRADUATING WITH A
FOUR YEAR LIBERAL ARTS DEGREE
THINK THEY PAY $50,000 PER YEAR
THAN THE ACTUAL MARKETS
DICTATES.
THEY ARE GOING INTO THIS I'M
GOING TO COME OUT AND EARN
$100,000 OUT OF COLLEGE.
NOW ARE NOT.
UNLESS YOU GO INTO FINANCE OR
CORPORATE LAW FIRM.
YOU ARE NOT EARNING $100,000
RIGHT OUT OF COLLEGE AND YOU
DON'T NEED T